Speaker 1: Why don't we go instead to Evan
from, is it pronounced, Harrogate?
Speaker 5: It's surrogate, David Harrogate,
Speaker 1: welcome, sir.
Speaker 5: Thank you very much.
I had a question just about kind of Argentine
public opinion on the Falklands, of course.
OK?
Sure.
Three.
Four question because I'm kind of I don't
really know how to get the public thinks of
government opinion on the issue.
So it's just kind of wondering, you know what,
the kind of public opinion and what the government
think is, what is your opinion?
And it might not be analogous, but do you
think there's any kind of tie one type analogy
to this point or not?
Speaker 1: I don't think that with the Falklands,
there's much of a Taiwan analogy, at least,
that I would be able to articulate.
But this is this is a good question.
It's the it's the 40 year anniversary of the
Falklands War.
The Falklands are these islands off the coast
of Argentina, and I am from Argentina, and
I know that people may expect me to have some
particular hot take or maybe even a biased
view because I'm from Argentina.
I mean, listen, the my understanding of public
opinion in Argentina is that most Argentineans
believe that the Falklands should be Argentinean.
My view is that that that's not at all clear
to me.
If if you look at the history, I don't know
the full history of the Falklands, but you
can definitely find periods in the hundreds
of years ago where different populations were
there to say who controlled it.
I just am not enough of a student of it to
say,
Speaker 5: but to me, yeah, go ahead.
So I think I think it was French originally
and then it was kind of abandoned for a while
and then it was kind of flicked between Spanish
and Majority British.
Speaker 1: So yeah, and so listen for me,
the you know, sometimes you'll see Argentinean
soccer matches and people unveil flags that
say the Falkland Islands are Argentinean and
stuff like that.
For me, it's an unusual hill to to look to
die on.
I recently saw because of the anniversary
and Argentinean news they brought like three
veterans from that three Argentinean veterans,
and the framing of the entire segment was
like, Obviously, the islands are Argentinean
when it's like not at all clear from history
that that's the case, and I know that people
on both sides will make very strong arguments.
I think it's politically ambiguous at best.
Speaker 5: Fair enough, I think because one
of my friends, what's in the oil industry
out there?
I think if you have the food stamp on your
passport, you're not, what's going to happen
to you?
Speaker 1: That may be the case.
That's similar, that's similar to if that's
the case.
That's similar to there are there are Middle
Eastern countries where if you've been to
Israel, you're not allowed to go in that.
That reminds me of that.
There's one other historical note I would
mention at the time in at the time 40 years
ago when this war took place, it was very
stupid to think that Argentina was going to
be able to beat, you know, the UK in a war.
Like, obviously that wasn't going to happen.
And there was a very cynical nature with which
there was propaganda value to appearing or
attempting to fight this war because of what
was going on in Argentina at the time, starting
to get out of this, you know, military dictatorship,
government in this type of thing.
And so a lot of people would look at it and
say it seemed really stupid to think that
Argentina's military could fight the UK.
And it was, and the reason was it had propaganda
value.
To some degree, I could
Speaker 5: go, Yeah, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
Yeah, good.
I was I figured at some point someone would
ask about that because of the because of the
timing and someone did.